so to sum up you have three world
historical tech booms
all three are geared to full global
markets but to really solve
these big challenges we're going to need
politics politics
can and does screw things up as we
mentioned but the flip side is that
politics matters
good politics can solve problems that's
not to say that politics is
random the basic pendulum swing between
progressive and conservative errors it's
back and forth that's played out over
american history
but we watch how power shifts to more
people-based power and progressive eras
and then back to more business power
in conservative era it's how the core
values move from a more collective sense
in progressive areas
to a more individualistic sense in
conservative era we've watched this
pendulum swing over time back and forth
in fact if you go back 80 years very
similar situation to today
the 1930s we had extreme political
polarization and paralysis we had
mounting authoritarian nationalism
but that opened up a long run of a
progressive era really a 40-year
boom this was the textbook case strong
government
build infrastructure spread wealth the
democrats dominated that era but both
parties work within the context for
example nixon
extended the great society as a
republican but
the end of that run in the late 70s it
was becoming outdated
out of ideas out of energy and so the
handle them swung again
and so then you watched essentially a
conservative era opened up
1980 brought ronald reagan to the
presidency in about a 40-year run
of the conservative dominated time the
boomers
dominated the politics they're much more
individualistic and turned out to be
conservative
the republicans dominated but both
parties worked within
bill clinton reformed welfare for
example but again by the end of this
period the last decade it ended up
outdated out of ideas
and pretty much corrupt so i would argue
a strong
case we're entering another progressive
era this is not wishful thinking but
it's built on
the inexorables this time demographic
ones
these cycles are driven by deep
demographic forces that build
ascendant coalitions the first is
a generational shift the dominant
generations of an era
largely drive the politics generations
have personalities and value sets
that pretty much hold through life the
gi generation coming off the fdr
drove the last progressive era the
boomers coming off
when reagan ascended kind of drove the
last 40 years
so what about this one that's opening up
it's going to be driven by millennials
now these millennials have much less
stake in the current society they
amassed
very little wealth in the last run and
they are much more transformative in
their thinking
think bernie sanders that's who is
behind him
but if you then add the generation z
that's those people born from 1997 to
this generation of generation z is very
very similar to the value
set of the millennial generation they
seem to align very clearly in all the
polling up to now and it looks like a
very little distinguishes between the
two of them
we're going to see with those two
generations a double-barreled
power that's going to push for more
transformative change at the same time
if you look how it plays out the boomers
are literally retiring in mass and dying
off
by 2040 the youngest boomers not oldest
are now age 75 and the oldest
they really are passed away by 2040 the
oldest millennials are just
hitting their 50s and they're pretty
much running everything the generation
behind gen z
who knows might be budding conservatives